الرئيس ترامب مغرم بتذكيرنا
بأن الكثير من الآخرين
عانوا من مرض كوفيد 19 ، لكن إليكم الحقيقة
لكل 100000 أمريكي
يموت 40 على الأقل وعدد الحالات الجديدة في
ارتفاع
كبير وفي الوقت نفسه تعافت أجزاء كثيرة من العالم
أو تجنبت العبء الأكبر.
من الوباء تمامًا ،
لم تكن هناك استراتيجيتان متماثلتان ، لكن
خبراء الصحة العامة يخبروننا أنه في
جميع أنحاء العالم كان هناك بعض
القواسم المشتركة في الأماكن التي فهمت الأمر بشكل
صحيح ،
لقد تعاملوا مع الفيروس بجدية ،
وتصرفوا بسرعة
عندما أغلقنا كأمة
في الواقع فقط  تم إغلاق حوالي 50 في المائة
من الأمة فيما يتعلق
بالأشياء الأخرى التي تم السماح بها في العديد
من البلدان الأوروبية ،
تم إغلاق 90 95 من جميع الأنشطة بإستراتيجية واحدة سريعة والإغلاق
التام
هناك الكثير الذي لا نعرفه عندما
ظهر kovid19 لأول مرة
قمعت الحكومة الصينية
التقارير الأولى عن الفيروس الذي يقوم
بإسكات المبلغين عن المخالفات مثل الدكتور لي وين
ليانغ
الذي سيستسلم في النهاية
للمرض
ولكن عندما أصبح المقياس واضحًا ،
قادت الصين الطريق
مع استراتيجية الإغلاق ، فقد أمروا
سكان ووهان البالغ عددهم 11 مليونًا بالبقاء في
المنزل ،
ثم زاد عدد القتلى الذين بلغ عددهم 62 مليونًا بحلول أوائل
فبراير
في مركز الزلزال ،
لكن معدل الوفيات الرسمي على مستوى البلاد
لكل
100000 هو
كانت نيوزيلندا واحدة من
أوائل الديمقراطيات التي أغلقت
بعد أسبوعين فقط من اكتشاف حالتها الأولى
في نهاية فبراير ، حيث أعلن رئيس الوزراء
جاسيندا أرديرن
عن الحجر الصحي الإلزامي على
أي شخص يدخل البلد
الذي كان أقل من واحد منحنى منحنى حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد.  تلاه حظر على دخول جميع
غير المواطنين والمقيمين تقريبًا على
الإطلاق وبعد هذا الإغلاق الكامل ،
أفادت الحكومة أن أكثر من 20
شخصًا لقوا حتفهم أقل من واحد لكل
100000 ،
وكان منحنى إيطاليا هو أول
دولة أوروبية تتضرر بشدة  بسبب فيروس
كورونا وإثبات أن كوفيد 19 لن يبقى في
شرق آسيا.
لقد اكتظت المقاطعات خاصة في
منطقة لومباردي المنكوبة
وتجاوز أكثر من
مائة طبيب
في أقل من شهرين من
اندلاع المرض الأولي هناك ،
لكن الحكومة كانت تعلم متى ستغير
المسار في نهاية المطاف لإغلاق البلد بأكمله ،
كان عدد القتلى المبلغ عنه في إيطاليا.
أعلى بنسبة 58 لكل 100000
من الولايات المتحدة ، لكنها لم تعد تتسلق
كثيرًا بعد الآن ، فقد
أصبح منحنى cobit الآن أسفل الدنمارك كما
تبنت الإغلاق المبكر
للدولة الأوروبية الثانية بعد
إيطاليا وقبل أن يكون
لديها وفاة مؤكدة واحدة ،
وقفت استراتيجيتها في تناقض صارخ مع السويد
التي  رفض الإغلاق لمتابعة
أقنعة مناعة القطيع لم يتم تبنيها على نطاق واسع في
الاختبارات الجماعية في
الدنمارك ، إلا أن التباعد الاجتماعي الشديد سمح لل الدانماركيين بأن يصبحوا من أوائل
الدول الأوروبية التي أعادت فتح أقنعة مناعة القطيع ،
حيث تم الإبلاغ عن 10 حالات وفاة لكل 100000
منحنى في طريقهم إلى أسفل.  هناك تقنية أخرى شائعة
للاختبار الجماعي للفيروس وتتبع
انتشاره في
فيتنام ، كان من الممكن أن يكون
كوفى  نقطة ساخنة d19
لكنهم كانوا يعرفون الكثير عن مكافحة
الأمراض ، وكان
لديهم أيضًا استراتيجية اتصال عدوانية ومبتكرة
، وتقول الحكومة إنه لم يتوفَ أي
شخص بسبب كوفيد 19 هناك ، كما أجرى
منحنىهم أسفل كوريا الجنوبية
اختباره الخاص بعد أسابيع فقط من
نشر العلماء الصينيين للفيروسات rna  التسلسل
لم يكن لديهم حتى حالة مؤكدة واحدة
في ذلك الوقت ،
فقط الكود الجيني الذي سرعان ما قاموا
بتكثيف اختبار
إعداد طريقة اختبار القيادة
قبل أن يصبح الأمر شائعًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم.
100 ألف
ومنحنىهم ينخفض في حي
أن الغرب يغطي أغطية الوجه التي لا نهاية لها والتي نوقشت في شر
آسيا عل
سنوات من الممارسة المعتادة ، رف
ت اليابان منذ فترة طويلة إغلاقها ، لكن الأقنعة أصبحت شا
عة بالفعل با
قرب من معدل الوفيات الرسمي العالمي ، حيث أصبح من
نى cobit الآن أسفل ال
ار الشمالي لأ
ريكا.  معاناتها من فيروس كورونا خاصة
في دور رعاية المسنين لكن الحكومة الكندية
كانت قادرة على الحفاظ على استجابتها
خالية
من أقنعة المشاحنات السياسية ليست
مثيرة للجدل في كندا ، حيث
سجلت كندا 24 حالة وفاة لكل 100000 ،
ربما لم يكن لدى تركيا
المنحنى للثقافة الجماهيرية لشرق آسيا
ولكن غطاء الوجه أصبح إلزاميًا في
الأماكن العامة
بطريقة  مرة أخرى في أبريل ، تم الإبلاغ عن وفاة ستة أشخاص فقط من كل
100000 شخص
وكان منحنىهم منخفضًا.
kobit 19 جديد ويتطلب
الابتكار
هنا في جامعة أكسفورد ، على
سبيل المثال اكتشف العلماء
قوة الستيرويد ديكساميثازون على الأقل
وفقًا للأولية  النتائج ساعدت ألمانيا على
تجنب أسوأ ما في الوباء جزئيًا
عن طريق زيادة
سعة وحدة العناية المركزة بشكل كبير ، حيث ورد أن 11 لكل 100000
ماتوا هناك على
طول منحنىهم